George thanks so much for willing to do this interview and I don't want to embarrass you
but I know you're clearly one of the most distinguished and successful scientists
and did you also always know you wanted to be a scientist.
I was originally going to be a mathematician and it turns out I didn't have the brains to do that I was
cured
and I was really good at washing dishes so I become a chemist How early did you know wanted to be a mathematician
Oh that was part of the sort of adolescent feeling that the closer you got to mathematics the better off you were so
there were mathematicians and there were physicists
and then somewhere down the road there were the rest of us it was OK were there
scientists in your family my father was a chemical engineer so my first introduction to Science as it were was
pouring coal tar through a little hole to measure the viscosity of coal tar black
and I was a technician he was a chemical engineer who made concrete repair compounds so  was he happy that in the end you
became a chemist
I came from the Midwest in the Midwest what real men do is they go into business or they go into the army
and as a absolute worst thing just before you go into the street you go in teaching at university
but it was sort of OK because I was at MIT and there were engineers at MIT it wasn't bad.
Are you who yourself surprised by kind of the way your career has developed to be honest I've never thought about it
but I'm happy with the way my career has developed because I've reached my geriatric whatever
and I wake up in the morning I love it it's great stuff what what what are you looking forward to every day.
It's a combination of things what what's interesting about science is that you have the opportunity to do things that
are important to people and you have the opportunity of following your curiosity and it's fun
and you can actually make a living doing it when working you and so as a chemist I mean I would kind of not know.
A better person to ask about the nature of molecules I have to think about I think it was Feynman
who said that supposed that all science disappeared
and there was like one bit of knowledge that we could transfer to future generations he would do was say something like
All matter is made out of very small particles
that that perhaps is the best clue to give Do you agree with that. the thing about chemistry is that's chemistry that's
chemistry everything you see is chemistry so that if you really want something that has the characteristic that
is universal it's molecules and how you construct reality based on atoms. now there is a little business of the mind
and what happens in between matter and mind is a different story but that's molecules too
but going to to the matter this moment or something so what do we learn of the fact that things are made out of little
building blocks what does that tell us. it tells us about the enormous variety that one can get from a pretty limited
set of things. the periodic table is a pretty substantial list
but most of them don't show up very much I mean the number of occasions during the day in which you see Prometheum or
something like that it's a very small Yes On the other hand if you just imagine the variety that comes out of carbon
and hydrogen nitrogen oxygen it's what we call life and that's truly phenomenal
and so the idea of the the almost almost infinite variability of forms of matter and function
and use that you can get by taking a pretty simple collection of starting materials I think is one of the most
remarkable things that I know. if you think about that variety you know we might naturally think about all the
materials we find you know rocks and lifeforms that we explore that we discover.
But I guess we're also now in a phase where we kind of kind of starts to build things that haven't existed before.
You can build many things that haven't existed before
and for which there has been no imaginable use. I mean a perfectly good example is a silicon and transistors
and the Internet but you take a perfectly ordinary
and fairly commonly available element which usually in nature occurs in a slightly different form
but is nonetheless silicon and you take it and you clean it up
and then you write lines in it in interesting ways
and all of a sudden it starts doing computation for you how on earth does that happen and of course we understand it
but that's a combination of just the particles we were talking about but also electrons
and then this other intangible stuff called information
and it's the mixing of the three that produces such interesting and remarkable results. do you feel that it's the.
Purpose that kind of led to the material or did the material led to this kind of unexpected
Useful purposes. there's a very interesting book that's appeared recently called The Idea Factory which is the.
A history there are many history of Bell Labs but this is
one history of Bell labs many histories of Bell Labs go along the following narrative that is they say brilliant
physicist unconstrained by reality produced condensed matter physics and the Internet transistors
and the Internet and all the rest of that laser wonderful example all the terrific yes
and it's a good story
but according to the guy who is running Bell Labs at that point it is unrelated to reality because in fact Shannon
and try for and Bardeen and the rest of them were all brilliant physicists that's not the issue
but they were basically making a more efficient and profitable telephone system
and so you know the thing about utility it was all focused on improving telecommunications
but there was a function yes people wanted to talk to their
brokers in New York or whatever that might be
and so since that function couldn't be accomplished by anything that existed they had to make up something new
and they tried other things and ended up inventing reinventing the world
but it was the desire to do something new not the desire to invent per se that I think made it happen so this is a
great lab that makes all these products which is called Nature right and evolution so can you say something how.
How does nature operates and how does technology operate where are the differences or perhaps similarities.
In a sense there's a similarity because if you believe Darwin and I'm a great admirer of Mr Darwin.
Nature operates by the idea of fitness what does fitness mean you get into wonderful arguments about what fitness
means but it basically ends up with the idea that whatever processes got us here got us here rather than porpoises
or snails or something that kind
and part of the reason we got here is that we are able to invent things that do not otherwise exist to accomplish
purposes some good some bad which other creatures haven't been able to do so well so what got us here was the ability our
ability the ability of our particular evolutionary experiment to do something us as human beings
and the interesting thing about that of course is that if you say that what accounts what counts is experimentation
and new ideas
and adaptability we're probably not the only thing that's ever going to be able to do that so there will be other kinds of
adaptation evolution and so if one looks into the future and ask are we necessarily the end of the line
and the best thing that will ever happen I don't think there's much evidence that that's true
but you're making the point that if you look at our technology
and how develop it that in some sense it's evolution that brought us to that point. it's evolution
but it's evolution in a funny sense because you can make an argument that one of the golden eras of science was the
period between.
The fifty's
and now there's an enormous amount of stuff that happened a lot of it happened because of World War two I mean the
the inventiveness that went into winning the war or not losing the war produced enormous benefits at the same time
and you know many of the things that happened earlier can be associated with good
and bad motives Yes So it's a question of how we use things in the argument is that science is is agnostic about this
and amoral I'm not sure any of that's necessarily true
but there are good and bad uses for most of technology so you say it was some kind of selection mechanism operative
operating the point too because we were really fighting for survival and what will we do with nuclear X. Where
X Is power
X is weapons
and X is who knows what it's going to be if you think particular let's first focus on what the more kind of material
science part if you look at the. Coming of new materials now. what we know and what is still out there to explore.
I think it's safe to say that the vast majority of forms of matter we haven't discovered yet.
How do you see this process going
and how do we find our ways in this kind of infinity of possibilities Well the question is what do we want to do
because it's the function that drives invention Yes
and one characteristic which is not always clear from the outside is that invention has a kind of ramp quality about
it that is coming up with an idea can be fairly easy there are lots of good ideas demonstrating an application is a little
bit more challenging whereas you have to knew something know something but the actual process of taking the idea
and taking it all the way to what we call a product
but even more so to a market where lots of people want it is very expensive
and very difficult in fact so that at the end science becomes technology if people want the function that it provides
Now what function do we want. right. and.
I think you can make an argument for example that the functions are probably the same in some sense that they always
were we want to be fed we want to have our children raised in reasonable ways we want to be safe we want to communicate
we want to be amused and each one of those will be served in different ways
but one of the interesting changes now is I think we've become accustomed the idea that information is probably as
important as things and we are growing accustomed the idea that machines may be as capable
or more capable than we in certain tasks and so you put together us,
Other parts of life machines and information
and you start having a world which actually doesn't look very much like the world of just one hundred years ago
and you feel that it is this combination of factors that will become a driving force for exploration you know Will
machines for instance help us explore maybe the machines can only do the exploration
but of course what they learn we can use
but we do we want to go and land ourselves on Pluto certainly not in the near term we have a problem so you mentioned
also kind of the whole I mean biology the life sciences are our own bodies are part of that kind of nexus of how do you
see from your point of view and I think as a chemist you're like perfectly positioned the material world and
and life and how are these two worlds interacting at this moment and what will bring the future.
Well that question is I think one of the more interesting questions around right now because there is a fundamentally
interesting issue there which is.
There is matter and there is life and are they different or is life just matter
and I have a prejudice in this which is.
Hypothesis let's say and that is we have matter like this which is stationary
and then we have matter of a different sort and.
The example I like is a flame which is matter but it's doing something
and it only really exists because it's doing something it's generating energy and you mix you mix methane and air
and you let it burn and you get a flame.
What's life and one argument is that life is a very complicated sort of flame you mix glucose for breakfast
or in my case caffeine with air and you burn it
and by a very complicated process you end up with a behavior which is not giving off heat and light
but it's giving off Beethoven and this conversation that we're having Yes And is that is that all there is
or is there something else there that we don't understand
and I think that's the great question Is there something we say emergent something that is not anticipated by existing
science that distinguishes life from everything else
or is it simply a marvelously balanced by some set of processes that we don't understand set of molecular processes
I could imagine that you know again  from the chemical point of view you might be perhaps biased to think the latter
that you think that it's just a very complicated process I don't know that just is the right word because you know it
just is a way of being a little bit dismissive. what to me is so interesting is the idea that if you can have
static matter you can have dynamic matter you can have living matter
and you can have thinking matter then this whole process leads you to the idea of how on earth
and why on earth would you arrive at something that was dynamic in the sense of being alive anymore
or even more so being dynamic and thinking intelligent intelligent matter
but the importance of the question I think is that if you can have intelligent matter based on hearts and blood
and whatever then there's no reason why you couldn't have intelligent matter of a number of different sorts if you if
you think and perhaps more kind of a gray scale or you have various. Kind of gradations in which life.
Matter is alive
or intelligent. might these questions be answered soon in terms of real objects appearing perhaps produced in laboratories that
are kind of exploring that intermediate area. there are I think two questions there. one question is.
Is there are there examples in which that line is already blurred Yes And I think there are many of them
and it one that I think is worth thinking about is simply a frozen egg. A human egg.
There's no chemistry going on it's doing absolutely nothing there is nothing in that that would suggest it's any
different from a rock but you warm it up and all of a sudden it's able to do something different
and you see in the same in the sense the same thing at the thought perspective because a human egg
when fertilized isn't thinking there's nothing to think with and when the baby's born it's not thinking much
and there's thought going on but it's probably certainly not self-aware
and then you end up with all of the semantic problems that you
and I have in trying to understand what thinking is about it's a continuum both of these are continua. so what that says
to me is that you can go from something that is not alive to something that's alive and from something that is not thinking to
something that is thinking in a continuous way
and the thing about continua is that they usually go on yes so we are not the end point of that curve where not the
end point of the curve that's right and so you say isn't it dismissive to think that we're just a flame
and the answer is no absolutely not because what you want is more complicated flames right
and that gives me a great deal of optimism that whatever we are a thousand years from now is not going to be what we
are right now. so I could imagine there are
least two kinds we can kind of have objects which are more kind of in between life and.
dead matter but we can also think of that these things will start to kind of enhances.
Is that something that you see happening soon. well is a self driving car fundamentally different in its function from a
cab with a really bored taxi driver I mean the word taxi driver is it's almost certainly safe
but the board taxi driver is probably not thinking about a lot including driving the car yes
and whatever set of systems is driving the car in and in the vehicle that's unmanned is something quite different
but it they're both sort of operating on a low key so yeah why not why can't we have many variations on complexity
and why can't we more interestingly begin to combine them. are you envisioning seriously that you know artificial
intelligence or deep learning processes will start to kind of change not only our lives
but perhaps also the way we kind of do science and discover things. but isn't it already happening because after all the.
We have had our the pleasure of having our younger son home with us and.
It's very clear that he is thinking about things in a way that's fundamentally different from the way that I've ever
thought about things I mean the Internet has rewired his brain let's assume for the better
but I don't know that to be true
but it has to do with the fact that for him the idea of all information is available you just assume it of course all
information is available now what you do with it
and how your intuition works it works along different veins so it seems almost guaranteed that this process of us as
adaptable creatures adapting to an environment which now has all this other stuff going on which wasn't there before
you know it has to happen it's af if there's some new competitor come along or some the temperature is changed
or whatever has happened. and so evolution is kicking in again. evolution is kicking in. well how do you feel as.
Particularly I think you mention the Internet and the way we're communicating it's not only operating at the individual
level but also the kind of amount of connectivity the way we are connecting to other people and other
But it's really all that it's it's really it's amazing
and well Does that give a different perspective on what it means to be a human being you feel.
What's a human being. well instead of just looking at us as individuals that in some sense we should now look really as a
as more as a collective.
Process. what I think you can argue
and we will see how it works out is that the Internet has rewired the brains of our children
and grandchildren in such a fashion that they are part of a collective as opposed to being isolated
and there are good features and bad features but the integration is very much a work in progress
and what will come of something in which not only is all information available
but all opinions are available as we are beginning to see yes plus
or minus with who knows what wild oscillation in the system as we begin to shake down in trying to understand what it is a
collective intelligence is like but a collective intelligence could be a next step
and it would certainly be very different from what we're doing now. if you kind of try to have a kind of a broader
perspective
and you see this kind of development or technology which you just said you know is really speeding up the last say fifty
years.
Do you have the feeling that we're kind of entering a new age in terms of technology what the role of technology will
be. Something like perhaps comparable to when we had like the Industrial Revolution or something.
I think the answer to that is absolutely yes. the question that I struggle with is what's the form going to be what's the
characteristic What's the characteristic because if we have enough matter of this sort to do many things
but we're just beginning to explore the intersection of this with this with information yes you end up with a very
different.
Kind of picture and it's not clear that I
or even you will live long enough to have a sense for what direction this is going
but I think the direction is going to be different. if you're speculating now I think clearly you know machines
and technology are becoming more and more important.
In the end will it be about us the story
or are we just kind of an intermediate phase that kind of passes the torch to perhaps the smart machine
or something else. we know there is the argument
and I think you may have heard about this from Martin Reese that we're just a little glimpse in between a period in
which you don't have sentients on the one hand
and then you have the real thing which lasts for a very long time and is based in silicon
or does something else I don't think it's easy to see the answer to that
but it certainly is true that you can understand that there are things that the Internet.
Can do that we can never do because I've spent a lifetime learning stuff a very brief lifetime learning stuff I die
it's gone but that won't happen with with other forms of memory
and intelligence they will be there forever. well your scientific achievements will definitely live on
and be carried on so aren't we in science in some sense also part of a much longer chain.
We are I know that we all like to have the idea that there is some residue
There isn't you know what happens is you understand stuff it's incorporated into things
and then immediately is taken for granted so it's not that we don't contribute
but there isn't much residue. it's the flame. it's that's right you turn it off it's gone but while it's there it's hot
and it's useful. talking about machines you know you think that in the future there will be more machines around us for instance
robots. Well you know there's an interesting word that you just use which is machine yes is a.
Structure that thinks as clearly
As we do
and can do things that we can't do allthough it operates on different principles aren't we dismissing it a little bit to
call it a machine. my lawn mower is a machine. I'm thinking about something rather different yes anyway robots.
Robots were developed of course originally to replace people in tasks that were not doable or difficult
or unpleasant than lifting body panels into an automobile assembly line or working in a mine or things of that sort
and that's worked really very well
and there are a series of what our machines which have the unpleasant characteristic that if you happen to be standing
too close to one of them when it swings its arms
it simply cuts you in half and doesn't notice. so one of the things is beginning to happen now is the development of
what's known in the trade as collaborative robotics meaning robots by which I mean very broadly almost anything that's
a machine that interacts in a dynamic way with its environment.
Robots that are designed and do work cooperatively
and safely with people. it's a very important kind of distinction because with cooperative robotics one can imagine.
The step in which on the one hand we already have us thinking together with machines computers I think all the time
we're very happy with that and if we can now add to this something in which we interact with machines
and maybe even machines that look like us although I don't think that's necessary as a part of this then you fuse the
two together with the with the corporeal self
and the information thinking self in ways that you can't tell the difference then all of a sudden we've done something
which is really remarkable which is depending upon your point of view creating a living or thinking pure competitor
or cooperative species and how we make that out will.
Depend upon how things go I can't answer the question. are you in any way worried that.
These cooporative new species will kind of dominate us or take over. in the short term no
and we have a wonderful example
when people bring up the issue of aren't robots taking jobs yes of course robots are taking jobs
but in the nineteen thirty's.
There was a very important class of robots introduced not called a robot but it was a washing machine
and a dishwasher Yes And what these did was to take fifty percent of the population otherwise known as women who were
spending their time basically washing things get rid of all that and allow them to go on
and do all the other things that people yes women men do so liberating liberating what it did was to create
opportunities to do more interesting things and so if we assume that what will happen with.
Advanced information systems artificial intelligence robotics whatever it might be if we assume that that will take
over some of the less interesting jobs
and there are many of those then the question is will we be clever enough to have other things that need to be done in
which this yes can work
and the answer to that of course in a kind of I don't know ethical sense is yes because picture number seventy percent of
the world's population still lives if not in poverty in difficult circumstances
and one could go about basically improving the standard of living. health housing education for everybody
or we could do something else and we'll probably try both.
I just want to also kind of come back to evolution
and as you said you know now at this point we are at this phase where technology enters and becomes part of it
but if you trace back in the other direction we talked about the kind of. Mysterious properties of.
Matter that has come alive I know you also think about the origin of life. right.
Because that's somehow the essential question that might be the point where we go from one one phase to the other
what are your thoughts about that.
To me the origin of life is the most interesting question I know in science right now I mean absolutely the origin of the
universe in space and time these are wonderful questions
but we don't actually have very much contact with the origin of the universe so it is not an everyday event for me yes on the
other hand you and your colleagues are everyday events and where could they have come from. I have no idea
and the characteristic of a good scientific problem is you don't know the answer before you start yes
but it's all well and good to say that you have a flame
but how a flame becomes the remarkable set of things that represent it is represented by life is not at all obvious
and there are two parts to this question there's a there's a part which is Darwinian evolution so once you have a cell
how does the cell become over many many many generations how does it become Beethoven in a vague way we understand how
that could happen how how do you take random sludge being a radiated by a U.V.
Rich sun and boiled by volcanoes and things like that and have that turn out to be the first cell I have no clue
and so what's wonderful about it is that I have a feeling there that at least in the detail we don't understand what's
going on at all but
but and the but is interesting what it does say is that it's possible to take things that seem totally disorganized
but have energy
and have them by some process bootstrap themselves into something that is totally different in terms of its characteristic
Yes we don't understand really how that happens in very vague terms yes
but how does it really happen I don't know. I mean if you wonder about the origin of the universe itself it was
intellectually of course very stimulating question and.
The same is true for asking what happened four billion years ago on planet Earth
but I could imagine that if you that the question of the origin of life is also quite relevant.
Now studying complicated processes etc something it's not only it's something that you could possibly replicate
or could show processes that we weren't aware of. perhaps
but that implies that if we're going to do it now it implies that we sort of know how it happened because if you look
at what seems to be required to make the simplest cell it is so complicated that it doesn't seem likely to have
happened by accident there has to have been some direction in terms of going downhill in energy
or something we don't know what that might be
and I don't think we know what that is there's a real difference in the opinion of the community that thinks about this
and I happen to think we don't have a clue there are people who think we're almost there we can go from pond scum to
the first cell Yes And then there are people who think that once you've got to the first cell you don't have to worry
about the rest of it you just assume it yeah yeah well how do you think that in the end we will settle that question what what kind
of do you at least see a pathway of investigation getting to the answers Yes I think there are pathways of investigation so from
the kind of approach that we take not knowing how to do it we ask the question of how do you take reactions
and how would reactions begin to interact with one other cooperatively how would they self assemble
and if you could do that if you could find out principles which would suggest that then you might be able to think that
maybe in this environment that set of things might have been and have become a group not of five separate reactions
but five reactions that are somehow working together and talking to one another
but what I just said how the reactions talk to one another we know how it happens in life now
but we don't have any idea how it could have happened to the life then and so it's a wonderful problem.
George we're talking about origin of life. I just want to make a little detour what you feel about life in the
universe. Are we
Alone. we don't know. yes. I mean the issue there is that if you're in the model I'm in which says I can't see how it
happens if it happens by accident it's so improbable that I have no way to get my arms around it but of course.
You know the sort of number as you hold your arm at arm's length and look at the size of a quarter
and in any direction that's a billion galaxies included in that and the billion galaxies has ten billion suns
and most of the Suns have planets
and they're experimenting all the time with everything I have no idea how to think about what's going on several years
of years over billions
and billions of years so there's lots of room for things to happen if I had to bet I would say that it's one of two
possibilities either there's only one or it happens all the time everywhere
and I don't know what the answer is. You think we can find out if we find out somehow the origin of life will it also tell
us something about.
what could have happened. can happen at other
other planets. I think it will answer everything if we have an idea that it it actually is not so hard you
know maybe you have to have the right conditions then with all those experiments it's bound to happen over and over
and over again
but there are probably events that are very rare I don't think we have any idea how often the universe firms forms
how often does nothing
burp into something how often does lifeless burp into life I don't know how to estimate that kind of number
I like that word. The Big Burp. the burp yeah the Big Bang it's the same B but it's another idea.
But you know the issue of evolution is also interesting in another sense
when Darwin thought about evolution he was thinking about finches and.
And the Galapagos finches and he was thinking about predators and prey
and surviving in competition with other competitors at the beginning if you think about the beginning there were no
competitors and the first cell had no living competitors but as it was
and probably what it had to do more than fight off competitors
and breed fast it had to fight off the consequences of meteor strikes and volcanoes
and things of this sort so that it may well be that what at the beginning was Darwinian evolution was actually
robustness the ability to survive dramatic change
and then that evolved into the ability to run faster than either what you wanted to eat or what ate you
and now the question is for the future yes what is going to be the vector for for for evolution what will we be
running toward or running away from and I think it will be very interesting if we both run away from
and towards something which we have created.
That's an interesting idea so we are one of the very few species that likes to be both predator
and prey for ourselves. so you're also telling us that we are kind of we are struggling with many of the issues that we created
ourselves many of the issues we create ourselves. what are the things that you worry about. what do I worry about I don't
know I don't worry about much because there isn't that much you can do
but the kinds of things that I think in a personal sense one worries about is.
Every one has a vector mine happens to be children. I care about children
and so as a child you are basically raised in our society to do work and ideally work that makes a difference
and meaningful work whatever meaningful is. If we find that we've handed everything over to.
Some other form of machinery then we've got to figure out what what people do.
What do people do to fill the day and that I think is a little worrisome
because I am not sure even now in Western Europe
and in the United States we have the constituentive problem that there are more people than there are good jobs for
people and when that happens everyone becomes mischievous
and mischievousness amplified with nuclear weapons leads to real trouble.
What do you see as the role of science and particular also technology in this I mean you could argue again you know technology is
operating on both sides of the equation in some sense you know it's creating lots of problems
but often it's also seen as one of the few solutions of these problems. there's no shortage of problems I mean just think for a
moment we have the environment and the environment everyone is interested in energy and everyone is
interested in CO2 we all recognize it's a problem
and we really don't have a good way of solving it. probably the best way is going to be.
The most acceptable way will be to reduce energy usage yes the other way of course is to reduce people
and the most benign way of solving both of those problems is probably education
and education isn't very popular so I don't know whether we've got that
but there's that kind of issue we are creating we as human beings are creating a social construct that didn't exist
ever before in history called the Mega city so fifty million or more people living in a small space
and we have no idea how these things operate but they have to operate well for for the people
and I think about this as being a purely chemical materials problem you have energy coming in you have food coming in
you have waste going out you think about stuff spreading both information and epidemics you have to do things with the
individual components but that will be done by a distributed system I mean it's a wonderful problem
and then you have. And you see technology in some sense as having opportunities to that. I think that will
happen. will happen yes.
One has in I think a very interesting construct in Europe called Ludvigshafen
and Ludvigshafen is the home of BASF.
Which is one of the few you know real chemical companies standing
and it's an enormous plot of land which is basically one factory and a mega city is almost the same thing
they are the same basic kind of constructs. stuff comes in energy is used stuff goes out
but we know how to run Ludvigshafen because we created it. yes. we don't have any idea how to construct a megacity because
it created itself. there's a very interesting question I think if you look at the usual definitions of life you know
self-aware energy using dissipating food in stuff out self replicating would you say that the city was alive.
I would. yeah. I mean it seems to me to have many of the right characteristics. so that's. we've talked about the
Internet
but it may be that cities fall in the same category. anyway there's the population of the world that is still poor
and hungry. I mean an enormous number of problems there. there's the basic question of how we deal with the detritus from
the past there's there's just an enormous number of problems how do you ease the pain
and suffering of dying because we're all going to die. how do you do this. so there's no shortage of problems the
question is how do you provide the education the interest the resources so that people are engaged in solving these
problems which will be what we call jobs as opposed to watching their handheld devices which is not a job
or making things even worse. right. Well I don't know if it's going to make it worse
but it's a little bit of drawing a blank card. is this. We were talking George about the problems in the world and I
want to ask you is that motivating your own research if you go into the lab are you thinking about.
Adressing some of these big challenges. it is a major motivation.
And my argument for it is that my salary and the salary of my students is paid for by people who deliver the mail
and pump gasoline and things like that
and the process you can follow the money. the process is that they produce money they in corporations produce money
which they give to the government which we all give to the government not because we're good people
but because we go to jail if we don't
but in the back of our mind is the idea that something comes out of it the government spends it for security
and education
and good things of that kind then the government of course has no way of actually doing anything with money because it
just is sort of a bag man so the government takes the money and gives it to a tiny fraction of it to universities
and sometimes to corporations on the theory that this makes for better outcomes
and then the universities have no way of doing anything either so whatever they come up with knowledge or invention
or whatever it might be has to be handed to another entity which is generally called a company to do something with. yes
and all of a sudden that produces something which society recognizes the person who put up the money recognizes as
a benefit but if you don't go through that it becomes self-referential it becomes.
Academics saying that we deserve to be supported because basically we're stunningly beautiful
and actually we're not we are just like everybody else and so the world is full of problems
and both from the point of view of helping to pay the bill you get the money you should give something in return
and also because it is so immensely stimulating to work on a problem that you have no idea how to solve we should do it
what are particular problems that motivate you. the one that we work on is we're very interested in health care for the
developing world and in much of Africa some parts of
South America Western China there are lots of places where things have gone wrong actually in much of the Middle East
now for different reasons. their people have very little access to health care they have very little access to hospitals
they can't do what we do in the United States which is we feel sick we go to the emergency room
and all of a sudden all the panoply of stuff is available. so how do you how do you provide help
and my argument at least in part as a chemist that you can't fix it if you can't measure it so that if you want your
physician you want to help you have to know help at what and that's diagnostics
and so. it's knowledge of the body. knowledge of the body and knowledge of the disease or the injury
or whatever it might be so the question is how do you provide information in a way that's accessible to people who
do not have front end hospitals working with them
and it's a very interesting problem because it actually super imposes almost on problems in animal health and the
problems in environmental monitoring and the problem of the city and other things
and what one asks as I would say more an engineer than a scientist in this regard is taking everything that you know
can you come up with stuff that helps to fix this problem in a way that's affordable
and easy enough that anyone can use it and it's simple and you can't really screw it up yes
and I think the answer is yes but it is not straightforward
but on the other hand probably it will involve some very kind of high advanced technology and investigations right I mean
it's you're not doing basic stuff here. you're really exploring. I think the answer is yes
and no. the actual work that we do is to make diagnostic systems that are based on little pieces of paper
and this. the origin of this idea was that we were looking for some way of making. Systems that.
Pump blood around and things of this kind in which we could adapt something that existed before for that purpose
and what we settled on was making comic books
but I was making comic books if you've ever seen a rotary press you know it generates enough pieces that big
or enough area if you think about this way to cover the surface of the earth
and you want to run in thirty miles an hour in a you know a sixty foot web it's amazing so that technology was there.
all we had to do is in a sense think of how to use it and that part is is actually trying to make things low end
and as simple as possible and simple is not easy. a transistor is simple but it's not easy
and then the high end part of it is that the assumption is everywhere that healthcare now will not be ever again just
patient and doctor
but rather patient doctor archival patient based database epidemiology that covers you know good fraction of the world
history of all diseases of that sort we're not there yet. A huge dataset. Huge data sets
and so that's the highest end so putting these things together is what in the sense is interesting how do you take
something which is designed at the level of individuals to be as simple as they can be
but at the level of collectives is more sophisticated than we can really imagine. thinking about also the collective So
the kind of immensity of data for you know perhaps everybody's life history and medical history.
It's kind of interesting that somehow
analyzing this is really a collective thing. it's no longer we somehow do this as a species as a
planet.
But you know even there you see it very much just looking around any room. you can tell if you walk into a room pretty
much even not a doctor who's healthy and who's not and and the big things are weight.
Exercise you can tell that by how people move not smoking and you can tell that by watching them
when they smile their face either breaks up in normal crinkles or in plaques and.
You know they have to look basically slept
and they get to get enough rest it's not all that complicated now lots of other things happen
when stuff begins to go wrong but we have a model in the United States in Europe in Japan
and many places of high end end of life medicine
and it comes from this basic idea that life is invaluable so we will spend any amount of money to keep you alive
do anything that is necessary. anything that's necessary this doesn't make sense to me
but if you take that point of view then you tend to focus on people who are already sick rather than the obvious which
is keeping people healthy
and you know my idea is that drop off the edge of the cliff rather than slowly sink into the swamp like a baby
hippopotamus in La Brea
George are you fundamentally optimistic about where the world is heading where our life heading I'm fundamentally
immensely optimistic but I don't know optimistic about what
because I don't know how it's going to come out. do you know why what motivates your optimism.
I think as a species we have tended to get better
and life is not as miserable I spend very little time worrying about whether I'm going to be set upon by robbers
whether I'm going to make it past my thirtieth birthday you know these kinds of things are not probable. It was not that
long ago. it wasn't that long ago that it's one hundred years ago that all of this was unknown. children died of perfectly
we regard perfectly preventable disease. what's happened a little bit is that is the genie out of the bottle problem
we've.
Released the Internet we have nuclear weapons we have the ability to do things which we use for good
but which if we're dumb we will use the wrong way
and so the question is a little bit Are we smart enough to keep the car on the right side of the road
or do we insist on driving in the wrong way. I found interesting there was an article I read by John van Neumann I think
from the mid fifty's with the title Can we survive technology.
And his conclusion was that it's like basic human qualities that help us answer that question just decency careful
deliberation are you agreeing with that yeah
and the argument that comes into technology and comes into science which I actually quite profoundly disagree with is that
it is a subject which is distinct from ethics
and human values. Ethics and human values do not help you solve problems in quantum mechanics on the other hand
without ethics and human values you don't know what problems to solve or how to solve them
or what to do with the answers once you have them so one of my major problems with education now at least at the
gradular level is that we teach students what to do with enormous skill but we don't teach them why to do it
and is that the right thing to do and I think not for them
and not for society you think that we need these kind of moral and ethical dimensions to literally to survive.
I think we need them to survive in a more direct way I think as a student if I were going into a field science would be
one because it is so interesting and actually has the potential for impact on society
but I would like to have the feeling that I'm doing it because it's important not because it's career advancing
and that's something you can do in science it's not necessarily something.
You can do if you are in other professions some other professions
and to minimize that potential pleasure of doing something that is not only interesting and technically challenging
but also helps other people seems to me like a worthwhile thing to do. Are you worried that you know.
Our technologies and our insights become so advanced that they basically are understandable to many we talked about.
the quantum and quantum mechanics and you know many people have not a clue what is this is
and this might yet be driving our technology. Well yes but I don't do you have a clue of how the Internet works
and I don't know nor do I I mean I know how a transistor works sort of yes but do I really know and one of my.
One of my annoyances in life is that I spend a fair amount of time on airplanes
and on the sides of airplanes are these things called Wings and the wings hold the airplane up how they do so.
I have never quite believed that it works out
and yet it goes up. that's right it's a miracle it's right it's astonishing to me
Yes And you know
when you start talking about the more sort of homey things like watching a baby develop It's unbelievable how does this
happen no it's not technology but if you say that technology
and life are just parts of the same different chapters of the same book then there should be common principles.
George you talked about the wonder of seeing an airplane go up
or a baby develop right is that sense of wonder important for you just as a scientist. what I live for I mean curiosity
is a phenomenally useful characteristic for a human being to have because you're never bored because you can never
understand the world around you completely
and so there's always something interesting going on. so you're motivated by that
what you don't know. motivated I'm amused and interested and then some
Small parts of that become motivation and some even smaller parts become problems to work on so
but you know if you look at anything and say how does that happen you can never answer the question
and so it's an endlessly interesting business. You have some kind of intuitive image about how much we don't now know how
much is out there in terms of things to be discovered and explored
but there's also there's a certain humility that comes from looking at something recognizing that you
understand finally how it works and then coming back a week later and recognizing that you were completely wrong
and you have it totally off base does and that happens over and over
and over again is that true were there moments in your your own career that you were totally wrong Yeah
and well I mean potentially every moment any time every day any time I say that I understand it I know I'm wrong it's
just a question of how long it's going to take to find it out
and what the nature of the wrongnesses is. is that fundamental to science that you're always going to have are is always
kind of moving
it has to be because how. the wonderful thing about quantum mechanics in particular is that it describes a world
that we can't really understand. let's assume it's right yes which I don't do one hundred percent know
but let's assume it's right and how do I understand it
and it's things like interference for example I used to think this was OK you know interference was OK because it was
it was something that happened with electrons whatever an electron was or a photon or things like that
but now I find that Mr Zeilinger can take.
Atoms and molecules actually big molecules Yes and run them through two slits
and it does whatever happens. It behaved like an electron. like an electron Yes I have no idea how to incorporate
that idea in my universe
and I think I always think quantum mechanics you know whatever the amount of introspection I think you would never come
up with that right. it is something we were taught by nature and we were very difficult students
and it took a long time for us to appreciate it. and then these arguments
that say that perhaps spacetime is quantized.
I mean I have the words
but if you say to me time is quantized then that raises the question of what's going on in between the moment. the bits of time
ah yes and how do I describe that and it's clearly not an understandable
notion now it may be that I phrased it wrong
and it's something different if you think about it in a more sophisticated way than I can you can get your grip your
mind around it get a grip on it
but I can't. Are you surprised how far we came in terms of understanding the world around us I mean it's seems to be
absolutely spectacular
and there seem to be no signs like forbidden for human beings. Well yes I amazed because of course.
It's always relative to what
and if you say that there's some gigantic examination that we are involved in and there's a score of zero
and we're clearly not a zero and then there's a score of one hundred in terms of understanding
and I don't know now whether we're at five or ninety five in any of these areas
and one of the things about chemistry is that actually the basics of putting together molecules
and matter we understand to an extent we can use it as a tool box as well design. what to do is a different issue yes.
When you start talking. There is this question of basically you are the designer and what to make right
and I design where you have the materials that's right you understand the materials
but then if you take the next step and say that the problems now are megacities and public health and the poor
and the environment all of those are problems in which you're dealing with collections of things you're dealing with
systems
and the solutions for an individual part of a system are not necessarily the right solutions for the system you know so
we may have to redesign with a totally set of differ different set of design rules which are the systems rules as
opposed to the individual component rules.
And that opens the whole book again
but That's going back to our beginning of our conversation were you said we are a sort of grade of building blocks that you can make
anything out of it but if the building blocks have the characteristic that you make something
and it turns out to be exactly what you wanted to be
but exactly the wrong thing for what turns out to be the problem which you didn't understand at the beginning yes yes
you can stay amused doing that. that's right. George if you. Go to.
Part of the series is also that we kind of describing the various kind of I would say kind of personalities that we find in
science because we might study the same phenomena but there's a great diversity also in the personal approach and.
I'm looking here at this animal that's on the on the table tell me what it is
and why is it there. this is a wart hog and my wife brought this model back from someplace from Zambia
or wherever she was and I'm very fond of it
and one reason for being fond of it is that I do believe that in the idea of totems A totem is an animal that you think
might embody some of your best characteristics and so I have two and one of these totems is a.
Rhinoceros and the reason I like rhinoceroses is it's not a particularly bright animal
and it solves problems by going through the problems. Concrete wall you go through the concrete wall you don't go around
the concrete wall and I feel an emotional kinship with that
and then these are so beautiful these animals they are you know not maybe to you and to me but to their mothers
they are so beautiful
and so I feel I fit in that category too so I'm I'm I'm for both of these animals. if you look around and you look at your
colleagues do you see other animals in the natural I do I do I do I do
and they run all the way from the most glorious of creatures to others.
One it would be impolite to make that that two column yes two column Excel spreadsheet but it's there.
An issue which is an interesting one about which we haven't talked is the division between science and engineering
or more properly I think the fact that that's not all there is.
So the argument there's an argument now in the United States that science
and engineering are just slightly different colored versions of the same thing
and I think that's not correct because scientists really like to understand things even if it's not necessarily useful yes
and engineers have this wonderful enthusiasm for taking something that basically exists in some ways
and making it better yes I mean it is a different point of view but there's a third part of it
and maybe even a fourth part. the third part is invention and people who are inventors are the ones who go from not
and to one hundred or one to ten but from zero to one. give an example of a canonical example of an invention
and a canonical example of an invention is probably a transistor because there was no such thing before
and it came into being for a different reason but a stool
or a fire I mean these were. a wheel was invented by someone you know an invention is not necessarily a flash of
lightning it may be a process that gets you somewhere
but it nonetheless creates an idea a concept of how the world could be that wasn't there before yes
and so we need to be a little bit careful not to say that you can be a scientist or you can be an engineer
but that's all there is. perhaps a difference between inventing something
and discovering something. the two are related Well in one case you look at the world
and you see what's there that you don't understand and you abstract an idea from it
and that's the charm of much of the.
Interface between the physical sciences
and the biological sciences. life offers so many interesting opportunities to do that
but the you know the other is sometimes you just are curious you say Could this be done counterfactual thinking is
actually I think very useful in science as if you get up in the morning and you say the sun rises in the east
and you realise that what you're really saying is that every day I've looked at it the sun rose in the east
but what would happen if the sun rose in the West and you are sometimes led into pathways that are quite interesting
and sometimes you're led to go nuts. right you know yeah. both work. yes what about the other disciplines you know In particular
if you think about invention
of something creativity I also naturally think about the arts. you think about the arts Yes And they of course operate
in a somewhat different way
but with the same kind of process if you look at the Arts which is so far as I can see a human construct it's a
construct of sought and you ask how that happens and what do they come up with
and how does that work it's astonishing
and it you know part of that which is actually fairly interesting is that if you read as a child as I did science
fiction.
It's easy to look back and say well all they did was think about spaceships and the Internet
and life on other planets
but what you have to realise is they thought about all this before none of these ideas were there. I mean they
created. even nuclear arms. which come into being yes and it was an astonishing act of creation
and in the same way people create of course societies and they create personalities
and the people who do this know things that we haven't gotten a grip on in some way that is this is also about
the power of our imagination. how important is that imagination in driving this I mean and how do you.
Kind of explain this that we can see things imagine things that aren't there yet I don't think we know
and one of the interesting notion was about for example machine intelligence is that.
It is showing us things that we have not previously appreciated the interesting baby example was Alpha go the program
that had the characteristic that it actually defeated the world's champion Go that's not so interesting
but what was interesting to me was that there were apparently one
or two games in which the program made moves which the human player apparently would not have made now that's creation
and it is creation in a very defined universe with a tight set of rules but that's OK
and that we know that that will change. I found it interesting that actually this defeat of human beings by a machine
actually lead to a lot more interest in Go because particularly with this element that this might be an incredible.
enriching process
for understanding the game. one of the things that crops up in in science fiction is the notion of systems that can make
very rapid decisions
and if you look at an area which is tended to be one which stimulated great creativity in the sense which is war fair
and you find exactly that's going on because those systems make decisions in ways and at distances
and in wavelengths we can't begin to really get a good grip on yes so it's happening
and everywhere around you look you in your group has a drone drones didn't exist ten years ago yes
and now drones are everywhere now our little eyes you know flying around
and looking for us in interesting directions so the opportunities for change are absolutely everywhere if you're
curious about. You know can I make a bookcase fly yes I can make a bookcase fly.
We talked about artificial intelligence could you also talk about artificial imagination.
That's a question to which the answer has to be yes but whether you
and I can talk about it I don't know magination is the ability to imagine worlds that don't exist that's not enough
because it has to be an interesting world that doesn't exist
or a world that doesn't exist according to rules that people have not taken for granted yes
and it is counterfactual I think it's basically a notion of imagining what cannot be assuming it to be asking how you
get there and then asking what happens once you've gone there so there is perhaps a process
but it's not something which everyone necessarily does in a way that has an influence on those around them. George we
talked about the evolution of life
and you know from its very mysterious beginning through great complexity to the emergence of intelligent
life.
And now we're in this phase where certainly you know human beings but also you know very smart programs and machines
and computers are kind of linked together.
How do you see this I mean if you just take a almost like a planetary perspective.
That looks almost like the planet is coming alive
and becoming an intelligence by itself yes I mean if you threw out the issue of replication why not why not have a
planetary intelligence that consist of everything one of the more interesting technological things that's come along in
the last period of time has been the ability to read signals from the brain
and use those to cause intentional motions you know to run a robotic arm
or something like that it's pretty primitive at this point
but what it connecting our minds to sort of say the mind of the robot the mind.
The mind of robot yes and it's at the action it's a level not of thought but at the level of.
Action and mechanics but it's a step
and it's really interesting step to a world in which you don't have to have physical connections
to have things happen now you say that well there's no way of going from that to.
Something which is more to do with thinking on the other hand having tried Oculus Rift I can't tell the difference
between that world and the real world it's a virtual reality it's a virtual reality world
and so you put all of this together and all of a sudden you begin to imagine moving things at a distance
and looking through the eyes of those who are not you at these things in wavelengths that you can't imagine you will
build memories from that
and you will construct your own reality from that so I don't know that I necessarily have to think what you're thinking
but if I experience what you're experiencing it may have the same effect and I'm shaping your brain
and you're shaping my Yeah you're welcome to go at mine.
If you take even more a kind of a wider perspective think of it you know of the cosmos
and in the title of the series is the mind of the universe.
Is that a grandiose overstatement of what we are doing here on planet Earth.
Well we've got a problem when one goes long distances we think because of the issues of speed of light
but on Earth that's not such much of a problem really we we are a little limited
but not that much limited so is there any reason to think we couldn't have global connectivity we have global
connectivity you know it's just a question of having it adapt and evolve
and what it evolves into what are the what will be the evolutionary pressures on a system in which. There are no.
Competitors and because very. again it's only one. Like the first cell. that's right
but of course there was only one cell at the beginning and it evolved its own predators. yes. that makes me a little uneasy
this is outside of my lifetime but it's not necessarily outside of lifetimes twenty generations from now. yes
and in fact you can argue I suppose that hacking is a little first you know it's one finch throwing a stone at another
finch or something of that kind.
Going back again to the beginning of your life you told you were as a child interested in math and science.
Kind of looking back everything you've seen.
Are you amazed by just what what happened what you've seen in terms of science and research
and technology. you have to be amazed of course one is amazed
and one is amazed every day but there's a little bit of a problem in that kind of question because I would have been
amazed by almost anything as children don't know anything so everything is amazing I mean if you ask what's the best
scientist
and everyone who thinks about it would agree the best scientist in the world is a two year old yes who invents all these
Newtonian physics balls falling down
and all the rest of it while inventing language while doing all the rest is just truly phenomenal that's what they do
because they're really interested yes because if they don't get it right they fall down so it's
downhill from there it's downhill from there in a certain sense
but you know I think one would be equally amazed by just going out
and looking at the world yes that what you get in science is the ability to intervene
and that makes to me a world of difference I just think it's so much fun to figure out I think that my work that way
well if it works that way maybe if I poke here something will come out over there and I poke here
and it doesn't it comes out over here
and that you know that really gets you up in the morning thank you for sharing some of that fun with us it's been a
real pleasure thank you.